وفرت السعوديه التاشيره السياحيه لحاملي
بطاقه هيا الخاصه بكاس العالم اضافه الى
توفير منصه حاضرين لاكتشاف الوجهات
السياحيه في السعوديه والاستمتاع
بالفعاليات المتنوعه زميل عبد الرحمن
العصيمي معهد التفاصيل السعوديه
حامل وبطاقات هيا وبطاقات هيا معي ثلاثه
زائد واحد التي تتيح اصطحاب مرافقين ثلاثه
يستطيعوا اصحابها اصدار تاشيره سياحيه
تمكنه من الاستمتاع بالتجارب والوجهات
السياحيه قبل انطلاق المونديال ب 10 ايام
ايضا هذه البطاقات يستطيعون من خلالها
البقاء في السعوديه لمده ستين يوما حملوا
هذه البطاقات يحصلون على تاشيره دخول
متعدده الى السعوديه مجانا دون الحاجه
لدفع اي مبلغ مالي
[تصفيق]
فكره جيده جدا
اولا سبورت كاس العالم وثانيا دعم للاخوه
العربي انهم يتعرفوا على المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وممكن من خلال البطاقه دي ممكن
اكثر من مره فرصه رائعه تفتيح له انه كمان
يتمتع بموسم الرياض
وياخذ فكره جيده على المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
واللي يكون يعني ذاهب قطر
لمشاركه في كاس العالم كم متفرج ولا كان
مشجع يستطيع الدخول للسعوديه واخذ قسط من
السياحه المتوفره هنا يعني شيء جميل
هلا فيك الحب اكثر من 2300 رحله جويه
ستوفرها خمسه مطارات دوليه وهي مطارات
الرياض وجده والدمام بالاضافه الى المدينه
المنوره والقصيم للراغبين بحضور مباريات
كاس العالم هذه الرحلات ستوفر اكثر من
636,000 سعره مقعديه مطار الملك خالد في
الرياض الذي نحن فيه الان افتتح صالتين
دوليتين ثلاثه واربعه بعد تجديدهما
بالكامل لاستقبال مشجعي كاس العالم
والرحلات التردديه المتوجهه الى قطر ايضا
المطارات الاخرى شهيد التجهيزات خاصه
لاستقبال مشجعين كاس العالم والزوار
القادمين الى السعودي
[تصفيق]
هؤلاء السياح لن يكونوا في حيره من امرهم
عندما تضع اقدامهم ارض السعوديه منصه
حاضرين ستوفر لهم المعلومات حول الوجهات
السياحيه والفاعليه المتنوعه ايضا هذه
المنصه تقدم الدعم في حاله وجود اي
استفسارات او حاله طارئه بالنسبه للمشجعين
فقط عليهم زياره موقع هير فور يو دوت اس
اي المركز الوطني للعمليات الامنيه 9 1 1
هو الاخر يقدم الدعم للزوار ومشجعي كاس
العالم على مدار الساعه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من مدينه الرياض
العربيه